well the health secretary matt hancock
joins
us now uh indeed good news a second
vaccine
now online uh this is the news that we
were hoping for
absolutely this is really fantastic news
this morning that the oxford astrozenica
vaccine has been
authorized for use by the regulator
they've been looking very carefully at
all of the information that's come out
of the trials
and they've approved it for use which
means that we can
accelerate the vaccine rollout which is
much needed
and the nhs has done a fantastic job
over
december in making sure that the
the pfizer vaccine can be used right
across the uk
and especially focusing on the over
80s and those in care homes but
this oxford astrazeneca vaccine is
really good news we have a hundred
million doses
on order the the rollout will start
on the 4th of january and will
really accelerate into the in the first
few weeks of next year
and how many vaccinations will you be
able to guarantee
by mid-january well that depends on the
manufacture of this vaccine and
manufacturers
it's a challenging process it's
happening uh
partly here in the uk and partly on the
continent
so we're not putting a figure on the
exact number
but what i can tell you is that we can
now accelerate the vaccine roll out
because we have the two vaccines we can
go
faster than previously and also because
this oxford astrazeneca vaccine doesn't
have to be kept at that ultra low
temperature
it means that it's easier to distribute
for instance in uh in gp
settings and in in care homes it only
needs to be kept in a
in a normal fridge temperature rather
than in the super deep freezer
so it's very good news for accelerating
the vaccine roll out and of course the
vaccine is our way out
of this pandemic so it brings forward
the day
on which we can all get our lives back
to normal
you're saying that you can't project a
figure in terms of the number of those
to be vaccinated but the medics are
saying that really we need to be
vaccinating
two million people a week to prevent a
third wave and to make any inroads into
to combat incovid 19.
yes well the st the nhs stands ready to
to deploy
at pace uh at the sort of pace that is
needed
to be able to help us to get out of this
pandemic by the spring uh
i know that two million targets surely
must be what you're aiming for if that's
what
the medics are advising needs to be
reached well it depends on the
speed at which the vaccine can be
manufactured and that's why i'm not
putting a number on it
but what i can tell you is that
depending on that speed at which this
uh this this incredibly important
substance can be manufactured
then the nhs is ready to roll it out and
the nhs will roll
will will deliver the vaccine into
people's arms as fast as it can be
produced it is a it you know it's not a
simple product it's a biological
substance it's not just a
you know a chemical that you manu that
you make
and so that is a complicated process
and i'm confident though that the
nhs will be able to deliver these shots
into people's arms
at the speed at which it can be
manufactured and i'm also
now with this approval this morning
highly confident
that we can get enough vulnerable people
vaccinated by the spring
that we can now see our route out of
this pandemic
it's going to be a difficult few weeks
ahead and we know that and we can see
the pressures right now on the nhs and
it is
absolutely critical that people follow
the
rules and do everything they can to stop
the spread
especially of the new variant of this
virus that
transmits so much faster but we also
know all of us now that we can
that we that there's a route out of this
and um
the the vaccine provides that route out
we've just all got to hold our nerve
over the over the weeks to come
so until until the vaccine can make us
all safe
and that will be by late spring do we
think
it'll be by the spring um and we can say
that now with
confidence that uh we will be
we will be able to get out of this by
the spring um
and we'll roll out this vaccine will get
people vaccinated just as quickly
as possible and in terms of quantity is
there enough or will there be enough of
astrazeneca to vaccinate the
entire population well we have yes we
have that on order 100 million doses
of course what also matters is the speed
at which that can be manufactured
there's an important other point in the
decision by the regulator that's been
announced this morning
which is that the time from the first to
the second dose
is recommended up to 12 weeks rather
than the much shorter period that had
previously been
recommended having looked at the the uh
the data from oxford astrazeneca and
this is important because it means that
we can get at the first
dose into more people more quickly
and they can get the protection
that the first dose gives you so the the
the scientists and the regulators have
looked at the data and found
that you get what they call very
effective
protection from the first dose the
second dose is still important
especially for the the long-term
protection
but it does mean that we'll be able to
vaccinate more people
more quickly than we previously could
the
mhra who are the regulator will be
setting out more details of these
clinical points
later this morning but all of this is
good news for how we can get this
country
out of this pandemic and actually
it's good news for the whole world
because this
this vaccine is is relatively cheap to
produce because it's easy to
relatively easy to handle and just can
be stored at a normal fridge temperature
that means that it can be used it could
be used right around the world
and i'm just so proud of the team at
oxford university and the uk vaccines
network of the
national institute for health research
who funded this the nihr
um and the team at uh
at astrazeneca and the nhs who really
made this happen
it's a been a big collaborative team
effort and it's very good news
for for the whole world that the uk
can bring this vaccine that so many
people
around the world will be able to take
and get protection from this dreadful
disease
just wanted to ask because now there are
two vaccines online
will it be possible for people to have
two doses of
different vaccines in effect is it
possible to to mix them
or not well that is not
the approved approach the approved
approach is that you have
two doses of one or the other vaccine
up to between up to 12 weeks
apart those two doses um and um
the uh and obviously we're going to
stick rigorously to
what has been approved by the regulator
having looked at the
at the data at the tens of thousands of
people who've had this uh this
uh vaccine in the trial and do you know
what the efficacy is after
one dose and then after the second dose
how it increases
well the the regulator is going to set
out all of those details
later but what the clinical advisors
say is that the ask the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
is very effective from around two weeks
after the first dose the second
dose is still important for the
long-term protection
and that's why this remains a two-dose
approach but it is the gap
the window between the two doses of up
to 12 weeks
is very effective very very helpful at
allowing us to
vaccinate more people more quickly than
we previously could have done
just very quickly uh before we move on
because there now will be
a choice are you worried that that
people might prefer one vaccine over the
other and
hold out for that particular vaccine
have you put anything
in place to ensure that that doesn't
happen well
in order to get your vaccine you should
wait for the nhs to contact you
and the nhs will decide what is the most
appropriate vaccine for you but the good
news is that both vaccines are very
effective
and all that data will be set out
by the regulator later today
but people should should come forward
whenever they're asked by the nhs
according to clinical need
not ability to pay it you know in the
long standing tradition of the
of the national health service of which
we're so proud
um you'll be aware that essex have
declared a major incident this morning
saying that hospitals can't cope due to
staff sickness and
critical care bed capacity what will you
say to the doctors there how are you
going to help them now
yes well this this vaccine news is so
important because
in the short term in the weeks to come
we've still got a very difficult problem
to deal with and all of us need to play
our part every single person
not just in essex but right across the
whole uk
needs to do their bit to reduce
social contact so that they don't pass
on the disease especially because one in
three people who have this disease
have no symptoms at all but still pass
it on
and so in essex we've been
monitoring that very carefully there's
clearly significant pressures on the
nhs so if you're if you live in essex
then it is absolutely vital
even more so than elsewhere in the
country that you have no social contact
unless it is absolutely necessary
outside of your own household
and this is important to protect your
nhs locally
where the nhs the local authority are
working closely together
it's obviously worth giving that advice
to prevent the the health service being
overwhelmed
but they're actually saying that that is
happening now it's not something into
the future they're describing it
one group of doctors saying this morning
that the nhs is facing its darkest hour
yes it's a very challenging situation of
course one of the advantages of having a
national health service is that we can
ensure that support comes for those
areas that are under pressure from
elsewhere across the country
uh so i know that for instance the nhs
in
in cambridge is supporting the nhs in
uh in essex and and that we've done that
as we've seen peaks of this virus in
different parts of the country
so we've been able to bring in support
from elsewhere
but that doesn't take away from the fact
that we are facing a very
significant challenge in the nhs right
now
and everybody can play their part in
helping to protect the nhs
now and even more so you know let's
protect the nhs
now by following what we all know we
need to do
because it's only a few weeks until
we will have the the vaccine delivered
to enough vulnerable people that
they will have the protection from uh
from
from the vaccine which is the the root
out of this pandemic so let's
let's let's hold our nerve let's all do
what's necessary
of course we have those tier four
restrictions in place in essex
and everybody should
in essex and in tier four areas needs to
stay at home
unless they have unless they absolutely
need to unless they have
uh a uh a reason for which they have to
before we move on to
the the the tiering system many will be
asking about the
nightingale hospitals and why they
aren't being
utilized they were built at great
expense
millions of pounds spent on them they've
hardly been used
and now we're being told that they're
being dismantled
uh they're not being dismantled they're
on uh standby
and the uh and they are there in case
they're needed
now the other thing that we've done over
the summer is that we have
built more capacity within the nhs
we've physically built on additional
critical care capacity and the best
place to be treated if you are
a covert patient is in a hospital but of
course
the nightingales are there
in case they're needed so absolutely
give me the the medics are telling us
that
the nightingale hospitals may be there
but there's simply no staff
to to run them they seem to be white
elephants
no that's not true there's there is a uh
staff in the model
what the doctors are telling us isn't
true um well
i'm telling you what the doctors who
actually uh run these things are saying
uh and the of course they're there but
the the thing that we all
um the thing we're all working on
is obviously to support the nhs to look
after patients
in hospital uh and then to have the
nightingales back
up should that hospital space
fill up completely but the first and the
you know the best place
and to make sure that we treat patients
is in hospitals where they have
everything on
on site and then we will absolutely have
the nightingales we do have the
nightingales on standby as backup if
that's necessary
but of course we need to staff the
nightingales and
and that requires a um that
requires people to be brought in from
elsewhere
in the nhs and from outside in order to
make that happen
uh let's turn to tears and tier 4 being
the highest and
what more are you going to do today what
more can you do
aside from a full lockdown well you'll
have seen that the
there's been a significant rise in the
number of cases
the the highest number of cases recorded
yesterday 53 000 cases and so
we are going to have to take further
action i'm going to set that out to the
house of commons later today i don't
want to
preempt what i've got to say to the
house of commons
but i think everybody understands how
important it is to take the action
that's necessary to keep this virus
under control
and you know throughout our strategy has
been to suppress the virus
until a vaccine can make us safe and
now we have not one but two vaccines
that are ready to be deployed to make us
safe
it makes it all the more important to
suppress the vaccine
once we get through the next few winter
weeks until we can have enough people
protected to suppress
the virus very quickly because i know
you do have to go
can you clarify the situation on schools
reopening
next month what is the scientific advice
that you will be following what are you
going to do
well the there's uh further meetings to
finalize uh that decision later today
and i'm sure that the
education secretary will want to set out
the details of the approach that we're
taking
clearly protecting education and
children's education is incredibly
important
and we've tried to do that throughout
this crisis since the first wave
and the challenge is how to do that in a
way that
minimizes the the the the impact on the
spread of the virus
but it's very late with schools going
back in a matter of days
it's very late to be making this
decision isn't it well of course
one of the challenges in a pandemic is
that you get more information
all of the time and this new variant of
virus
is really really tough to deal with i
mean it makes
the the strategy of suppressing the
virus until a vaccine
can make us safe you know the vaccine
bit has just got a whole lot better with
the approval this morning but the
suppress the virus bit has got a whole
lot harder since the new variant
got really got going over
over december and now the majority of
new cases in the uk
are the new variant it is much much
easier to
transmit from one person to another
that's why it's spreading so much faster
so the challenge of suppressing the
viruses got harder
but thankfully the cavalry have arrived
in terms of
not one but two vaccines and we've got
to get those into people's arms just as
fast as they can be produced
final thought do you support the idea of
a circuit break in
football as suggested by sam allardyce
today
well i think that i i think it's
fantastic
that we've been able to keep uh football
going
uh through the uh for since the summer
it's so
important and i i it's absolutely a
matter for the football
authorities working with the culture
secretary to get this right
i am not going to i'm not going to get
involved in that
in that discussion i know how seriously
the
football leagues take
the need to keep people safe and how
seriously they take
uh the uh the the measures that are
necessary
um and i i know that they'll be taking
this decision
very seriously as well but i also know
just how great it is that we've got
football on the telly
and we're managing to do that behind
closed doors
even in the teeth of this pandemic matt
hancock thank you very much for speaking
to us
thanks for having me on